en fait ce qu'on va faire maxime je
donnais une petite combine en plus des
magiciens et depuis plusieurs mois tu
essaies de la séduire donc je vais te
montrer comment faire d'accor le plaisir
on va en faire un tout avec des cartes
m'apprendre de deux traits pts 6 passes
on peut bien avoir à la caméra je
l'utilisais j'ai pas de retour votre
nokia fait cenal s'inquiéter à ce que tu
prends le marqueur c'est le temps plein
je vais faire une grosse signature fait
monter les verts fermé je vais en gros
si nature s'il te plait ça fait très
bien et les graisses suivante qu'on va
faire on va le laisser sécher un tout
petit peu on va prendre deux trèfles va
plier en deux et en quatre je vais
simplement te demander de mettre ses
entretiens dans celle qu'a pété voilà
traitement top sexy j'ai fait la même
chose moi avec le cadre de coeur voilà
qu'on montre ici
pareil je prendre la carte je vais
signer
on va laisser ses charges que non mais
ça de côté et je vais faire la même
chose que toi tu es là carton 204 bon
tacle dessinée l'anpc leurs démarches
qu'il faut faire vraiment de demain
encore une fois on tourne autour
notamment des verts droit
[Musique]
attention voilà au la soul assez chaud
tu fais ça non non je peux prendre ta
carte doucement annoncé le nom de tous
côtés serge adultes sérieux aux côtés de
son côté ses côtés avant la mi-avril
tour du double dames devant la reprise
en direct et huard tombe c'est un peu un
shérif marteau
[Applaudissements]
je veux pas que le sang
là
ces deux questions
bien sûr comment tu fais le tour et 2
surtout à quoi il servait maxime n'a
rien la même chose mais en fait je
voulais te dire autre chose en faire la
même chose avec jean michel mr et à date
ah ouais enfin michel c'est un truc en
plus non c'est pas ces brèves et racé
coup dur pour faire la même chose en
fait tu sûr qu'un délire ya un truc très
bien tu parais tu vas si l'opéra de
sydney la tarte
voilà on fait exactement la même chose à
l ocha très bien donc ce qu'on va faire
pareil on va prendre date à voile a plié
en deux et en quatre ans la nôtre tu es
dans ta carte dessinée est pareil je te
demander de prendre la carte non classé
voilà je signe ici une lourdeur voilà la
leur pour le colonisé la bouche un
médecin traitant est pareil voilà vous
retournez voilà non comme ça face à face
ce que je veux faire
tu te ramasses cap la date parfait est
pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais regarde tu soulèves d'alata
quartier était sinueux [ __ ] si
j'hésite imagine stasi l'on retourne
franchement personne doit ensuite
dégénéré